hey Danny Lohner cake I see you looking
at my ass
mommy's stay on living like Stevie I
wanna give y'all ladies on my when I'm
coming to see you gotta wash up into not
last
that's some pretty solid advice for
every tuna box out there so wise for
someone so lean what you guys might not
know is that before I make fun of anyone
on this show I personally reach out and
ask for their permission I never do it
alive but what the heck
please welcome daddy longneck what's
good not your help daddy long neck
hey are you so skinny Nene no they were
lame for sure what condition I had only
no bonus
I can't gain weight another where are
you from Flint Michigan
starting to add up do I have your full
legal permission to tease you on
television
yeah I know all right cool what do you
say we give you dreads flip you over use
you as a mop no okay
what if I put a blanket over you and
have you riding my bicycle basket like
et no all right how about this we put
you in place of Rachel and every scene
from friends it's perfect
since you already have the haircut I
think that's funny
Oh what do you think we should do it
would be funny if I you know like no
like they're intense I'm following and
my face is up and I'm like okay orrible
idea stain lady like a titty stay in
ladylike them beating I have hit a new
low